So what do you think? In this
case, if we ask
Mercury Kobo to do the
work for us, we
are asking Mercury Kobo to make that work for us. Our work is going to be made by Mercury Kobo.
You all have had some unexpected misfortune.  That's a
shame, so let's
pay the 10,000 yen reward as promised.How about that?It's a
good story,
because no, you can get the reward without any more effort.I don't
like it.Let's think about it together and create it together.  If you make something and
sell the parts to someone else, you
'll be selling off the pride of the craftsmen as well.That's why Page Kobo has come so far.There's no
point in it.I don't think so, but that's
the way you hear it.  No one, including this head craftsman,
will accept such conditions, so I
refuse to discuss this topic.We will make the sugar confectionery under the new sanctions,
but don't worry, we
will make it in time.